Hôm quần phương một xác quyết nhất tình nình bình.
Hãy ngày sau khi cơ lúc sải tình hoàn quách qua đây,
những gì còn lại trên đường đi của lúc sải chỉ là gạch mọi nguồn găng.
Sau khiến tay, anh ngô văn yếu đang cố cứu chưa,
vất vát những gì còn sóc lại của gia đình.
Vừa anh cũng bị thương và đang được cấp cứu trong bệnh viện.
Hôm nay đến giờ thì cũng có cơ cơ quan chức năng là anh nhá bàn bệnh đúng chưa?
Đây, giòn giọt, kêu này nhưng có gì,
thì khoảng năng giống gợt,
còn năng ra số này,
mấy đi hết.
Tại chúng tâm ý tế nghĩa hơn,
vừa anh yếu cũng muốn người khác đang được điều chỉ tích cực.
Họ cũng đều là nặng nhên của chạc lúc sải kinh hoàn vừa qua.
Các bạn chỉ cũng kêu chữa ngô trẻ em,
thì bà nở tay em ở bị đứt gân.
Sao này có thể nào sẽ thông nằm được việc vì nặng nữa.
Gái thần phục hồi của nó thì của chạng, nó loộc.
Nhân bà nè, đáng đưa chúng tôi sẽ nghĩ kích thời.
Đó phía nó ngồi thêm thàn,
cho phía nhân.
Thế tính hình thả này.
Các phía nhân bà ngàn đều chỉ nó chú đây,
thì cũng tất loại nào ở đây.
Theo báo cáo của sạc quy nhất,
lúc sỏi là bốn người chết,
bẩy người bị thương,
chỉ mới tư cân nhà và các công chính phục trợ bị đồ.
Bị tốt mái,
bà bị tắm cuộc điện bị gá đồ,
với mất điện cho hơn 6 trăm hộ dân.
Ngay sau khi thêm tài xảy ra,
chính quyền địa phương đau vì đồng lực lượng hộ chạng người dân bị anh hưởng.
Hôm tác khá phục hộ qua,
đang quyết chính quyền của đã chỉ đạo.
Mà chẳng được quốc,
nó rất là thế chính thị trợ hộ,
phối hợp với nó,
thuân sống, tổ rân phố.
Hổ chợp và con là rộn dạc,
và nhạc cửa,
cũng như là đường trả.
Báo số mười đã gây thị thái nặng này với người và cuộc tại Ninh Vinh.
Với 3 mi bàn người bị thương vong,
mười chính gân nhà bị đồ sập,
tắm trăm hai người bà gân nhà bị hương hồng,
môi mốt điểm trường bị thị thịt.
Vì 3 diên dần tình Ninh Vinh yêu cầu các sá,
phường, mốt chỉ nơi ở tạm.
Gữ trưa miệnh phí trong người bị thương,
tổ chức tham hỏi,
lộng viên thân dân,
các gia đình có người thiệt mang.
Nông thời xử dụng nên xác dự phòng
để chiến khái tập chính xác hỗ trợ hận gấp trò diên dân.